غاريسون فوستر كان في قوات المشاة
مع قوات مشاة البحرية الأمريكية لمدة ست سنوات
حتى الآن يقاتل إلى جانب القوات الأوكرانية
وغاريسون أنا سعيد لرؤيتك
بوضوح، أنت تعرف
ليلة مظلمة مظلمة وباردة ورطبة هنا، لذا
أنت فقط  من الواضح أنك خارج
الخطوط الأمامية، أه في مكان قريب أيضًا، وقد قمت
بمشاركة بعض لقطات GoPro التي
تعرفها عندما تكون مرتديًا
سترتك التي ترتديها على صدرك،
وهذا النوع من إظهار وجهة نظرك أثناء
تجمعك  معلومات استخباراتية أه لمحاولة
استهداف القوات الروسية الروسية أريد
أن أظهر بعض الأشياء التي
مررت بها والتي ترغب في مشاركتها،
وهذه هي المواجهة الشديدة
التي خاضتها مع القوات الروسية
مؤخرًا قبل بضعة أسابيع فقط في
المواجهة  - هجوم تعرضت فيه لإطلاق النار واضطررت
إلى التراجع وأريد فقط
أن ألعب هذا الدور حتى يتمكن الناس من
رؤية القليل كما تعلمون للتعرف على ما يبدو عليه الأمر
في تلك اللحظات فقط
استمع بالتأكيد
وأعتقد أننا ننسحب
متحرك
[تصفيق]
لا أتذكر أن العقل هو
الأقرب،
هذا ليس مكانًا جيدًا لتكونوا رجالًا،
يجب أن نتحرك
ونجهز بعض البطاريات المضادة أو شيء ما على
ما يرام من خلال هنا
بوم
بنكر بنكر مرحبًا
بالداخل، هذا
رائع،
لديك غرفتي
وادخل  علاوة على ذلك، أعلم أنك
هنا منذ أبريل من العام الماضي في
زيارة قصيرة إلى المنزل بمناسبة ولادة
ابنك، نعم،
أنت تعرض حياتك للخطر لمساعدة
بلد آخر وأعتقد أن
الجميع يريد أن يفهم ما الذي
يدفعك وما الذي يدفعك  عليك أن تفعل ذلك،
جزء من الحامية جيدًا هو أه الكثير من
الناس لا يعرفون هذا ولكن
الأوكرانيين أرسلوا جنودًا إلى أفغانستان
بعد 11 سبتمبر. لقد كانوا جزءًا من أه
القوات التي كانت هناك ولم يكونوا
ملزمين بذلك  افعل
بي كذا وكذا، حسنًا، كما تعلم، لقد جاؤوا إلينا في
وقت حاجتنا ولا أرى أي سبب لعدم
الذهاب إليهم في وقت حاجتهم
أيضًا، كما تعلم، هذه منطقة كثيفة الموارد للغاية،
أنا لا'  لا نريد لروسيا أن
تسيطر على تلك الموارد ثم تستفيد من
ذلك لزعزعة استقرار العالم،
وأنت تعلم خلق المزيد من الحروب
الخارجية